you know i believe if you're a large
business call it a fortune 15 000 one of
the 15 000 biggest businesses in the
world you need to be producing a couple
of hundred pieces of creative a day a
day and as you know and there's people
watching though some of the companies in
the fortune 1000 don't produce a couple
hundred pieces of social creative in a
month or sometimes even in these i
welcome everyone to this year's netas
marketing summit building deeper
connections today and tomorrow with gary
vaynerchuk my name is nicole tan and i'm
the country director for malaysia for
meta and joining me here today on behalf
of neta i am very delighted to welcome
renowned speaker gary vaynerchuk or more
fondly known as garyvee to join us today
hi gary how are you
i'm very well nicole thank you for
having me
thanks so much for coming on our
fireside chat today you are one of the
world's top authorities for culture
relevance and operating in a digital
world your presence here is really going
to help move the needle for a global
audience so we're going to jump right in
as you might imagine more than ever the
internet is changing so many things are
changing and the battle for audiences
attention spans is just unrelenting
you're the authority on this how can
brands today connect with communities
and audiences and customers how are we
connecting this art of storytelling to
the science of
what are you seeing that hasn't changed
and what are you seeing that's new from
your point of view
well the thing that doesn't change is a
good story moves the world right you can
go back to religion
and and and
you know politicians and
great spiritual leaders those who can
communicate
whether through the written word
audio video or even through arts like
music and painting
sculptures these are the individuals
that and and organizations
if you look in the last
100 years of business
whether it's a coca-cola or a ford or a
proctor and gamble um these are the
organizations that tend to
win
uh and humans that tend to win
audiences
um so that never changes and never will
it change i'm sure the
person that was best at drawing inside
of caves many many many many years ago
was achieving her his goals and i
believe in 500 years whichever robot
slash human is best at it they will also
achieve their goals
i think what has changed is the mediums
right where the distribution is
and so
i think the biggest challenge for brands
today
inside of meta executives outside of
meta the agency partners and the brand
leaders
most people
have really not
gotten
the subconsciousness
out of their body
of being a television-centric
advertiser
the biggest elephant in the room
is that even
when you look at the execution
with creative
against meta even the way meta itself
does communication at times
on tvc
or other places
even the most progressive companies your
contemporaries the googles
the tesla's the netflix
the you know the casting of the
creatives
and the cr and the decision makers and
marketing are still grounded in
television mentality which is very
heavily
focused on reach um
and
and by nature
is not focused on relevance because
they're not making enough creative you
cannot win relevance
with very few pieces of creative it's
just fundamentally impossible look at
aipac
i mean geez right so many different
countries so many different religions
and then you get into things that are
you know very real everywhere in the
world
income levels gender
age
race
so
my hypothesis
is that facebook and twitter
and myspace even before them youtube
they came along in the mid 2000s and no
different than the radio the television
or the printing press
they became the communication layer on
top of the internet
which is obviously one of the most
significant inventions of all time
and they changed the context of
distribution
and actualized consumption today more
people
will consume a reels on instagram or a
tick tock or youtube short
today
then people will consume a newspaper ad
or a television commercial
and the world doesn't act as if
and so
the the thing that i see
is a humongous disconnect between the
amount of creative
and the context of the creative
and the nuances of the creative
that are needed on a daily basis
for fortune 5000
companies to produce
globally
you know i believe if you're a large
business call it a fortune 15 000 one of
the 15 000 biggest businesses in the
world
if you're global you need to be
producing a couple of hundred pieces of
creative a day
a day
and as you know and as people watching
know some of the companies in the
fortune 1000
don't produce
a couple hundred pieces of social
creative in a month or sometimes even in
a year
yeah i think that's interesting because
you know you know watch a lot of your
videos obviously and i follow you on
instagram and one of the things that you
were talking about was how like there's
a need for volume but also need for
quality and for storytelling you
mentioned about how that you can't have
it's difficult to get creative nuances
um in in short how are you helping
clients help have this problem shift
from this like long tv view
to
storytelling on short in uh quantity and
quality like what you think is
there's a couple of things one quantity
is not debatable
you and i
like can can look at let's use this
starbucks and we can look at their
accounts and we can say today they made
97 pieces of creative and you and i
would have to agree on that
on the flip side it would be impossible
for you and i to agree
on if it was all which 97 were quality
and not which ones do you like which
ones did i not like right it's
impossible right nuances yeah yeah agree
yeah
so my my answer is
you have to take a step back as an
organization and understand that truth
and until one
organization does they are always
vulnerable
if if one if you and i were the cmo of
nike and adidas right now and we were
making subjective calls
on the content our teams were making our
teams are in a very precurious position
because they are at the mercy of our
opinion not the fact of
what the consumer likes so
i think there's a couple things one
i think you can you can't qual quality
is like beauty it truly is eye of the
beholder if you look at reels and tick
tock
and places that
benefit
the audience appreciating the content it
is very clear that nobody on earth can
predict virality some of the things that
work on my tic toc and instagram youtube
shorts are things that i could never
have imagined
on the flip side things that i'm
positive when i post them that they're
gonna hit
don't and i'm a human being who's been
doing this for 15 years
every day every day
every day
and i'm good at it and i've been
successful and yet i
am often wrong of the tone and
temperament of the moment
of my audience
how agencies and brand partners
sit in ivory towers
in board boardrooms and think they know
is audacious at best and ludicrous at
worse
and so my hypothesis is
don't [ __ ] the creative people that
you chose if you're the cmo of pepsi you
get to pick your agency
if you're the ceo of the agency you get
to pick the people you staff
but after that you must let them fly and
let the
data quantum qual speak for itself over
a period of six months to a year
everything else crushes the process of
creativity
if you don't go with the route of volume
and letting people do their thing
you are slowing down the process the
meetings themselves become more
expensive than the output of the
creative
and most importantly
you will eliminate
finding right
and you will still sit in the audacity
of thinking you're right
and that is a very dangerous place for
marketers in 2022.
right i love that and i think you really
um i can really relate to that um i
think it's very interesting how you
break down storytelling into it's a game
of both volume but also creativity and
giving the opportunity for that
creativity and using the technology
to
maximize the creative opportunity almost
right so it's personalization powered by
technology so to speak thank you thanks
for sharing that um we're going to move
to the second topic if that's okay with
you
uh
i'm not sure if you've heard of social
commerce um so in southeast asia seventy
percent of southeast asian consumers
they adopt business messaging right and
i myself use whatsapp messenger
instagram direct connect with you know
um products and small businesses like i
just became a mom and like literally
everything that i buy for my babies from
instagram
um
you know toys and all that stuff what
are your thoughts on this sort of you
know some people say it's a quiet
revolution but i think it's it's huge
especially in this part of the world
what do you think of business messaging
social commerce like
what what's your take on that
you know i launched
an e-commerce business in 1996.
i
did a youtube show within the first four
months of youtube being alive
and in that show i embedded
the youtube video on a website
and linked out
the four wines that were on the show
in the wordpress
to my father's wine shop
so you're speaking to somebody who's
deeply entrenched in commerce
dna
um i mean also by being a global
character
the integration
in china
um the the
more integration in southeast asia than
the us
you know
i have actually been very disappointed
in
it personally as a fan in meta's speed
of integrating
you know commerce as a more aggressive
aspect to be frank i think
the opportunity is
enormous
i agree with you i i think
i think people who think it's a nuance
are crazy i think it's
the most important part of the
conversation
i mean if you really look at the
economics that are being captured by
influencers organizations
by creating awareness on social
but then doing commerce off of social
and the friction involved and how much
we lose in that friction in conversion
uh you know
i i you know it's funny as
one of meta's great strengths something
i admire quite a bit is when there are
trends how quick the platform the
organization for mark down
is ready to move into it
snapchat stories
that format of storytelling was a
profound
shift in communication
and
it was just a
brilliant move by
um meta to understand that they needed
to integrate that product into instagram
we saw a similar thing happen with two
separate companies clubhouse and twitter
spaces right
and so
but i think where meta should be
focusing more energy is innovating
commerce
instead of
overtly worrying about
um
short point video which i think it
should
but
i do think that
especially because
instagram
is such a visual medium obviously the
investment in short-term video is
growing
but
you know if instagram gets too far away
from its image
dna
some other platform is going to be able
to pick up where they left off
because
people want to consume pictures it's why
magazines still sell today even though
it's an antiquated medium
right
it's and it's also foundational to
humans so for me
the commerce opportunity both in video
both in qvc and shopping network like
dynamics like we see influencers going
live
i think there needs to be a lot more
innovation on the product side to
eliminate friction
um i i think that the opportunity is
extraordinary if for example instagram
was really strong feature-wise
in live selling i go live and it's and
everyone's credit cards are already
loaded and the ui is very easy to click
to buy one i'd probably be doing wine
videos right now for my dad's store i'd
probably be going on once a day tasting
one wine having a button there by now
but because there's so much there isn't
those features in place yet at the level
that i would want right i don't i i
believe that i am one of
50 million people
that would do that
tomorrow
yeah and i think that in this part of
the world especially people are finding
ways to do that with or without the
features to a certain extent i think you
know
business messaging is important to meta
and i think there's a lot of work that
we still need to do
but just looking at the enormous
opportunity in this part of the world
what excites you about business
messaging i think for me it's just
the personalization is a little bit
different from what you see in the other
forms of e-commerce but what are your
thoughts on it like what do you feel
distinct business messaging from the
rest of the e-commerce channels that you
you've obviously very familiar with
what you chop for me nicole the first
part one more time i apologize
no problem not saying that you know
i think you're really deep into
understanding all the different
e-commerce channels and i i think it's
um
we know the opportunity is really
enormous for business messaging and one
opportunity at least from my point of
view being here in this part of the
world is that it's much more
personalized the customer relationship
is very different from say the frictions
that you get whether it's on websites or
even on email or even
shopping on the feed
right of course and i think that's yeah
that's the unique opportunity that this
is well that's that's that's because
humans buy from humans
that's right that's right of course yeah
and so
you know it's one of the last
leverage points that a retailer that has
a physical location has is their sales
staff's high touch
and so to your point
to your point
live streaming or interacting
uh is one of those real mediums i i i
couldn't agree with you more i'm i'm
very
bullish on it i think it's a huge factor
and i think every platform playing in
social
needs to be thinking about it more than
they are and yes
people are figuring it out i i do it all
the time
but
i think that there is no debate that the
feature sets could be stronger for
the conversion of
sales within
live
social
executions and that's what i'm looking
for
and i think that there's definitely more
opportunity for
um
improvements both in terms of the
features but still you know we hear from
a lot of clients that they're debating
they're debating whether business
messaging is still something that is is
it is it a trend or is it something
that's going to to last
um do you see this as something that is
you know
for the long term or what are your
thoughts on that
i i couldn't uh i couldn't um
i couldn't understand how someone would
think that that's not a long-term
reality people buy from people
you know
the whole the home shopping networks
have been around for 40 years already
and those are on television phone call i
mean the thought that anybody thinks
it's a short-term fact i i i would like
to meet the human who's taking the
stance
that
buying through social is a short-term
chad i would love to understand their
logic
right right okay yeah i love it and
definitely
i i i get the point um it's definitely
not a short term fan messaging is here
to stay and it's going to get much more
prevalent um so you know the other topic
and i know this is definitely something
you're very passionate and interested
about i think if you go anywhere go to
you know talk to anyone in recent months
all of the conversation is around web
3.0
um you know including the metaverse
including nfts congratulations on your
50 million funding
um
for be friends really cool and there's
this whole entire economy spreading
around the concept
some people say that you know it's
happening some people say that it's 10
years from now
everybody's expecting this hockey stick
growth what do you think
is it going to change the way we live
work and play
how big a deal is this
it's massive but the timing is the more
interesting debate so
for everybody's watching if you look
back at
the internet hitting consumers in the
mid 90s
windows 95
it
it took some time the reason there was
such a
big internet stock
crash in march april may of 2000
was everyone got over excited
about how fast
and how prominent and if you were just
an internet company you were worth a lot
of money because people didn't
understand similar to why i made videos
last summer saying 99 of nft projects
are going to go to zero
because
the reality was
that
people were overvaluing the nft projects
just for being nft projects
um
right the consumer blockchain
is extraordinarily big
it is fundamentally enormous
the emerging vr ar world is also quite
big and important
the ability to own things digitally and
bring them into
a vr setting is very fascinating and
profound yeah um very obviously
obviously they'll be very open platforms
completely decentralized
and then there'll be these things that i
call web 2.5 which i think is where meta
and oculus will sit because obviously
it's a centralized
slash decentralized
uh mix right so i think that it's gonna
it's definitely gonna change the world
um it it it's so obvious to me that the
consumer blockchain
is going to
um
create
for transactions
what the internet did for communication
and so
it's a ledger at scale that isn't
controlled by anyone this is a very
profound hypothesis
and it's starting to play out already
right 8 000 people came to a stadium
to see me put on a super conference for
three days with all sorts of luminaries
and
all of those people were able to get in
because they owned a specific nft and
anybody who did not was not able to get
in
that is a very big deal
that is a very different reality and
whether it's airline tickets or sporting
tickets or
many other uh buying a home or
um yes so i think it is i think for
marketers it's an opportunity to build
relationships even potentially use the
nft as a gateway to first-party data
i think there's a lot here
and i think uh over the next decade
it'll become more obvious to a lot of
people the speculation around the
collectibilities
the collector's items
that
had beanie baby dna in it right
and so that is why you saw the
correction
but the overall technology whether it's
ethereum
or solana or something that gets
invented tomorrow
um
it's obviously we'll see
multiple blockchains i believe long term
we'll see that they're all interoperable
and i think we're uh we're in for an
amazing journey here over the next 20
years
yeah i i can't wait i'm really excited
about it it feels like you know the
early kind of internet days
but this time i'm older so i know what
i'm doing or a little bit more um
but you know a lot of clients ask us
this question what can we do now um and
i'm sure you get that question as well
like what what should brands or
businesses be prepared now in in ready
for this
potential change what would you advise
them
i think that they absolutely have to
start with education
um
they have to know what's going on
you know
too many decision makers don't
understand the platform the technology
uh too many of the top executives have
no idea
too many agencies are running around and
selling things
and campaigns and things that
are going to be more detrimental than
positive outcomes for these businesses
so i think
i think there's a lot that they need to
do
uh as far as education and strategy so i
think
this is where you know we have a company
called vayner 3.
bain mckinsey media monks i think
there's people running around that are
trying to
um play that role and i think that's the
right decision if i was the ceo of
coca-cola today
i'm spending five ten million dollars on
internal education and strategy
before i go waste 10 million dollars
doing bad campaigns
i think that's really
interesting
so i know we've got where we're kind of
running out of time it's always too
short um thanks so much for sharing your
thoughts and insights today so we have
the audiences from southeast asia and
emerging markets listening us today
you know southeast asian emerging
markets is one of the most resilient
fastest growing regions in this part of
the world what's the one key takeaway
and maybe like a shout out or
encouragement um for the businesses and
for the audiences that we have today
well listen we have almost 300 people in
southeast asia
all over the region with vayner
so i'm incredibly in tune to what's
going on the words of encouragement are
not needed and here's what i mean by
that
the innovation the creativity the
the ambition is the word i would use the
sheer
tenacity and effort that i'm seeing from
my employees
potential employees candidates
competitors
clients non-client executives
there is such tremendous energy in the
region across the board
uh and you know i'm i'm humbled by being
able to be here and share with everyone
my words of encouragement would be as
simple as keep going everything that the
region's been doing
for the last two three years four years
is very obvious to me to why there's so
much innovation and creativity and i
would just say more and more
[Music]